one of the things that I think always
inspired me about chess is the
personalities in the world of chats we
always hear these great players and you
know what they were like and I as a kid
you know I thrill to these accounts of
great players well there was a
tournament in 1975 in Vancouver BC
British Columbia that the great Paul
Kara's played it you all remember the
name of Paul Kerr as well Paul Kerr as a
Estonian Grandmaster was also known as
Paul the second because quite often
times he was second when he was playing
for the World Chess Championship cycles
you would somehow always managed to
avoid becoming the Challenger he became
known as Paul the second but he was a
great great great player and I loved his
well it was Paul Kerr as best games but
it kind of broke down into a trilogy of
books and I just thought he was just an
absolute marvelous player at the time I
was about I'm going to say an expert
player and a friend of mine really
strongly I couldn't play in this
tournament in Vancouver BC but a friend
of mine very very strongly suggested
that I go and I watch Paul Koretz and I
go i watch Paul Koretz why should I
watch him says you'll learn just
watching Paul Koretz so okay that was
very inspiring so I went up to Vancouver
BC and I remember he was playing a
master Alan was the Masters name and at
the time that fellow who Paul Koretz was
playing against was known as somebody
who who really liked to play the petrov
or the Russian
feds and Cara's white lady for the Allen
played the Russian defense and Paul at
the board was this consummate gentleman
you know she's very dignified old-school
manners very graceful and he moved the
piece says with just perfect like always
the piece landed in the middle of the
square not trying to disturb his
opponent at all and Allen played Knight
f6 and without hesitation just as if it
was the strongest move in the world
Karras played d2 d3 this was like a
great disappointment to us all because
we wanted to know how to refute the
Petrov effect
caris wasn't interested at all in
refuting the Petrov he just played d3
knight c6 Bishop e2 d5 92 and 1 in about
20 moves it was just a it was a thrill
watching Paul Kerr as and it was sort of
like the first time I had really gotten
a chance to see chess genius even though
I didn't understand it of course I just
like enjoyed watching the guy later much
later of course I started playing
against all of these great players from
the car Paulson the Kasparov sand nons
and so on and I understood that there
were levels levels of chess genius
levels of chess understanding that was
really really remarkable and they I'm
going to say it's the early 80s I had a
dear friend his name was Michael Spiegel
and Michael Spiegel is about a 2,300
master and he said yes sir I'm sorry to
inform you you'll never be world
champion he said to me a dear friend
why he says well there's two guys the
Vassily Ivanka and Boris Gelfand and
these two guys from the Soviet Union are
unbelievable these guys are like the
future of chess they're just what what
they do is incredible so the first time
I met Vasily Ivonne shocked I had a very
strange experience where at the board
playing and I would make my moves and
you know I don't really pay too much
attention to what my opponent was does
or doesn't do but I noticed that Yvonne
chuck was staring into space like he'd
be behind his board it was like he was
looking up at the ceiling and
periodically I started looking up as
well if it was something up there that
was going on right so it was sort of
like he would be looking up at the
ceiling he kind of rock softly and then
he would make a move right down his
score sheet get up walk around come back
sit down and then before too long he
would be staring up at the ceiling again
coming you know considering the cosmos
so to speak now okay
then of course I played with Boris
Gelfand now Gelfand was also the very
first time I played with him he was
really amazing because gelfand
was the direct opposite of Yvonne Chuck
instead of staring at the ceiling it was
like he was staring the square e0 so
like he's looking directly at the square
e zero and he would take a piece and he
flick it with his fingers round around
and he so we had one guy who was
interested in the macrocosm and then
they have a guy Boris Gelfand was
interested in the microcosm he is two
great geniuses another genius that came
along
Alexander Moore's evich you know do you
all know the name Alexander Moore's
image well in my mind he's easily the
most original player on the circuit
I mean when I see more Isaiah chess
games I just have a very very hard time
understanding what he's doing half the
time and yet he's easily in the top
world's top ten and when he's at the bet
when he's at when his game is at the
best he's just unbelievable I mean he
can absolutely destroy the very very
best players in the world what's really
remarkable is not only as he successful
in his checkmating attacks but it's
almost as if his opponents are prepared
for them they know that morisevic is
coming after their king and Mors evich
does it anyway and and successfully so
this following game is all the more
remarkable for me because it's a game I
completely don't understand more and it
has nothing to do with Moors Elvis's
normal style of approach which is to
kill your king sasha is white Peter
Svidler is black they're playing in a
tournament in thessaloniki in the world
grand prix events Knight f3 oh sorry not
wrong move and knight c6 variation new
mainline okay and now here I mean of
course you know there's thousands of
moves the Scotch has become increasingly
popular at one time Bishop c4 started
become quite popular still Bishop b5
Berlin marshals Rui Lopez's I mean and
Peters fiddler by the way is defending
the black side of the Rui Lopez quite
successfully in the recent candidates
tournament he managed a victory against
a celebrated victory against Magnus
Carlsen as black in the last round and
more zealots you never really know what
he's going to do
he produced Knight c3 okay after Knight
f6 you have the four Knights defense and
this has a notorious drawing reputation
probably you will be able to find games
from the 15th 16th 17th 18th century
with this opening position but modern
day players considered this position
really so balanced that a very few top
Grandmaster games today go into this
line of play so Bishop b5 and of course
Bishop b4 is like historical and one of
the oldest moves but in modern day games
it's considered that White's approach is
so modest that that black can be
aggressive and play the move Knight d4
in fact I played Knight d4 is black on
several occasions myself so Bishop a4
all very standard and now here black
faces a choice he could play Knight
captures f3 Czech Queen takes f3 and
after for example so move like Bishop c5
you just have to like white because well
thank you very much
White has a better development with this
Queen on f3 so black players aren't
playing knight c6 to d4 in order to
capture but instead their their approach
is to play Bishop c5 and offer offer the
pawn on e5
okay so the problem from black from
White's point of view I beg your pardon
is if white doesn't accept the offer of
the pawn on e5 if white play something
like castles castles d3d six black is
prepared to play the move Bishop g4 very
quickly and suddenly it's white who's on
out and in the unpleasant pin with this
Queen on d1 and it's knight on f3 so
white accepts and plays Knight takes e5
and these are all very standard moves
castles 93 attacking the bishop on c5
Bishop d6 598 now so far it's a funny
situation
not quite Fischer random with the theses
on the back rank there but the modern
approach to this position from white is
that actually black has good
compensation for the pawn specifically
the knight on d4 is a real e annoying
piece a bishop on a4 well it's not
really that great the bishop is pretty
good on b6 black has ideas of playing f7
f6
a real pawn sacrifice or simply just
playing d6 and any kinds of captures
help black enormous Lee one thing that
it happens also if that white castles
and after for example a move like d6
takes Knight takes White has to be very
concerned about a queen h4 and a Bishop
g4 ideas when black really gets a pretty
promising attack for free and again this
knight on d4 is a major source of
compensation
so Mars ovitch played Knight to d5 cool
before people have our suffering colds
as well as I have it looks like sounds
like Knight d5 okay
and now here we have a key moment in the
game and I can't say that Peters move
was bad
I think his move was fine he played the
move c6 okay so he just attacks the
knight on d5 and he tries to encourage a
capture so that after for example
captures and after for example c3 so
that the Queen can defend the bishop on
a4 after a move like b5 we get a kind of
a bizarre position where Bishop C - I
like blacks compensation here just very
fine I think black is doing very well
once he is able to play a move like
Bishop f5 White's in trouble okay so
nothing wrong with the move c6 but also
I think it was a crucial decision option
pardon me a crucial option for black as
well as the move
Peter played was the move d6 just
something that maybe you'd like to
investigate yourselves c6 was played and
morisevic played Knight III he wasn't
interested in capturing this Bishop but
what White's idea
I thought hopes re merely mine well what
White's idea I thought is simply and
then I was mentioning this knight on d4
is just a very important
eise for blacks compensation and what
white simply wants to do is play c3 and
just kick it back this bishop on e3 is
probably the bishop on b6 is blocked by
this night on e3 from being too
effective okay so far everything's fine
and again d5 I think that this choice by
Peter is just fine my own preference
again was just to play d6 and to try to
encourage white to trade and Knight
takes and again White's upon a head that
his pieces aren't that easy to develop
d5 okay more of Xebec castled I believe
let me just get this one up here
d5 castles yep okay castles and now we
understand Peters idea f6
and it really starts to make a great
deal of sense from blacks point of view
because okay so these guys are even so
what black is basically saying is please
take my pawn on f6 so that I could play
Knight takes f6 in that case White has
an extra f2 pawn but black isn't unhappy
at all if after takes Knight takes blood
and blacks mind if he could play the
move Knight to e4 you have two
beautifully placed knights in the center
of the board and me again be careful
about that move Queen h4 could be very
very annoying
so after f6 Peters a happy camper and
he's a happy camper for another reason
the other reason is that when I started
the lecture he's got the perfect
position against Moors evich because
there's no attack
blacks King blacks King is perfectly
happy more Zeva chess pieces are far
away far far away from blacks King and
black is the one who is hoping to doing
the attacking on the King side okay
so whereas I was watching this game
unfold
I found myself asking what the heck is
white going to do right have any of you
seen this game this game before by the
way yeah yeah you dirty ROG yeah I mean
what the heck is white going to do for a
plan I mean if you think about it do you
really want to play a move for example
like f4 so that after takes your idea
would be to take with the night and
maybe establish your knight on e5 well
something about f4 just doesn't feel
very right and again like what exactly
are these pieces this Bishop on you know
a mild criticism of Peters play so far
but if you think about it this three
pawns are a pretty good fence against
White's Bishop all of the diagonals for
the white bishop or basically blocked so
I began to think to myself question what
is white what is white going to do for
an active plan and anybody have any
suggestions that you might come up with
if you are white and you know you woke
up one day and you found yourself that
you are in this position is white what
kind of plan would you conceived I'm
interested in suggestions anybody want
to throw something out there please by
all means well yes sir please
we locate the night on the DL like this
night on d3 isn't like impressing
anybody right so you're suggesting that
maybe there should be some white white
should consider some idea perhaps based
on the line like pawn takes Knight takes
say something like night II one with the
idea of c3 and D for something like that
right and I agree that makes perfect
sense to me I like that as a suggestion
thank you very much and it was probably
something I may have played myself if I
had gotten this exact position therefore
the following idea by Mars evich really
kind of like stunned me he played the
move c3 and after Knight f5 he played
the move b4 I mean to say that this idea
this that this concept is hidden is an
understatement I mean from my point of
view it was a sort of light you know the
windows were closed the curtains were
closed I mean it just never occurred to
me to come up with such an idea and yet
if you think about it for better than a
half a klick suddenly it starts to make
sense this Bishop on a4 is well crap I
mean it's not functioning it's not it's
not at full power so to speak however if
we flash forward ahead and we imagine to
move like b5 and we made black capture
that pawn on d5 well then we could play
ideas like Bishop b3 and suddenly this
pawn on d5 is a potential weakness so
the idea before is to play b5 and to cry
try to break up this very powerful team
of pawns here
b7 c6 and d5 so at this moment Peter
played a completely natural move and
suffered greatly after words he played
Queen c7 and we can understand this move
from another point of view
so if from Peter's point of view what he
would like to do is capture this bond
that's obvious but what he would really
want to do is for force white to capture
so that he could bring his pieces out
with night eggs and he might be spying
ideas like Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop g4 lots of cool things going on
for black after the move Queen c7 and
again it's one of those wonderful
wonderful moves a mixture of defense and
attack the attack is clear the defense
is equally clear his idea is that after
a future b5 in case there's a weakness
well the Queen has defended strangely
enough after this position after this
move it's almost seems as if there's no
turning back with the benefit of
hindsight it would have been much better
for Peter just to simply say okay
congratulations you played the move a
four and you've induced me to play the
move a six which stops your b5 idea come
up with something else that didn't
happen Queen c7 was a choice oh there
was another variation I wanted to give
to by the way after Queen c7 how did
that go
buuut ethics yeah sorry so let's imagine
and go back here
imagine f takes for a moment Knight
takes Knight takes pawn takes Knight
here
this was also very interesting choice
from blacks point of view I mean he's
still a pawn down but I think his
compensation isn't our isn't so bad at
all so this was also a choice that Peter
could have considered I'm sure he did
be for Queen c7 and Mors evich now
played the very consequent and the
direct b5 he basically said when your
pawn back I don't care about material
why should I care about material I'm I
I'm more as evich I want to get my
pieces out as fast as possible we start
to see some ideas suddenly here for for
white after he's played b5 well F takes
was played so why don't we just do that
F takes e5 and after F takes e5 we start
to see this idea
Bishop a3 okay remember a moment ago how
that Bishop had just kind of been buried
on c1 it's like doing nothing
well suddenly after Bishop a3 it's very
nicely attacking a rook and after rook
f6 bang suddenly came the move oops
wrong wrong one
come on ah you dog night before
yeah night before okay
and you know again III think there are
so many more is at games of mores evich
where it's like the sublime beautiful
confluence of forces harmoniously
sacking the black king and suddenly like
Mars ovitch suddenly decided that he
stopped being a headhunter and instead
he's a pawn grubber he's got all kinds
of ideas now one and obviously is to
capture and capture and capture twice on
d5 for King Queen and rook suddenly it's
blacks pieces that are all like messed
up and and Peter played II for this this
was a an easy move to play and after
this
well blacks just dead busted instead of
the movie for I thought that black might
be able to resist with a move like the
ship d7 okay after Bishop d7 the line I
looked at was B takes c6 B takes c6
Queen b3
with very evil intentions of capturing
on d5 and capturing on a8 after Queen b3
I thought the line would go Knight takes
e
and King h8 this line I liked a lot I
saw the move c4 and after
see for a five Knight takes d5 C takes
d5 Bishop takes d7 Queen takes d7 oops
that's not what I wanted
Queen takes b6 I did mention that Moors
evich is a headhunter right and now
suddenly black is staring back rank mate
right I mean very very very typical a
kind of a combination in the position
isn't it just terrible I mean my
goodness it just kind of came out of
thin air
so to speak but this this line was very
very consequent night before
efore that's what was played in the game
and again I was thinking that well gee
if black had just played Bishop d7 he
would have been able to sell save
himself but this whole line is very
forcing essentially as black you really
can't keep your King on g8 any longer
and there was a reason why you couldn't
play just King h8 immediately I think it
was the sacrifices are too strong on d5
so we get this c4 very very nice move
just to break up the team over here
a5 trying to embarrass the night and
then this line of play yeah
so very very cool variation but II for
was Peters move now after E for came the
direct and consequential V takes c6
okay so a couple of things are going not
so very well not so very well for black
the first is that there are ideas of
simply sacrificing art well it's not
really a sacrifice but simply taking
this pawn on d5 taking this night on e8
so you win upon but not just any pawn
the whole position unravels another idea
from whites point of view is for example
after B takes c6 there was a line of
play I think that went Bishop takes c6
rook takes c6 Knight takes so what's the
idea here well in the immortal world
words of min EV Nikolai min EV gift me
or Queen gift me or queen when you're
Queen moves
let us choose a square for a moment
Queen b7 we capture this night and after
Bishop takes Knight d7 check and you win
this Bishop back and there are several
ponds up and everything is just going
exceedingly well so after this move B
takes c6 blacks position is simply
collapsing at this point a fiddler Peter
decided that it was time to go
in desperation mode he played rook h6 h3
Knight h4 a very poor chance of an
attack I've I've ever seen one however
you had to do something Knight h4 Knight
takes d5 Queen B 5 and B takes so in
this position essentially what white
wants is that after Bishop takes b7
sorry I meant to put that on the board
after Bishop takes B 797 check King h8
oops that was it what I wanted Knight g4
new main variation there's no attack
there's simply no attack and massive
amounts of capturing air in store for
black or he's going to lose lots of
material after Queen e5c takes b7 and
instead of Bishop takes b7 Peter tossed
in out Knight f3 check Queen takes f3
tags yeah Queen and black resigned
there's no there's no attack whatsoever
for example after takes the simplest I
think is Queen takes c8 giving back some
material because after takes clean you
can either recapture with the King and
well the sky is hanging on e8 there's
ideas like nighty 7 check there's ideas
like d4 simply killing the bishop so
that it can no longer influence play the
Queen on c8 not only attacks but it also
defends the pawn on h3 very nicely so
this is absolutely hopeless and again it
was here that Peter resign well it was
all very nice and we're just going to go
back for a moment because it started
from a position where remember when I
turned it over to yourselves and I said
what's a good idea for white it moved 12
and again he played c3 it's remarkable
that 9 moves from this moment White has
come
lately smashed black like off the board
and it just made this incredible
powerful impression on me that here
Peters fiddler is in the world's top ten
one of the really really strong
grandmasters of our time six time us I
was going to say USSR as let's say
Russian champion and he just gets
smashed on the board from a position
then I'm not even sure what white should
play and that for me was just sheer
genius so congratulations to morisevic
blows it was this great game right great
great great stuff
you